[Music]
in too many options news submitted by
Congrats Anton Christina
baby baby dog Amazon doesn't want to
answer how it chooses products for
Amazon's choice and everyone is confused
anyway know what yeah
like Sophie's Choice it's like the top
choice of a product you search know so
it's like on Amazon's like this is what
we suggest you buy in this this category
that you're looking for oh is it like
when you're about to put it in your like
shoppers also bought and then they
package it no it's like it has a black
across the top it says Amazon's choice
like however you put in like pencils I
don't have Amazon choice for pencils
like so they're just pushing you towards
that oh and I think a lot of people are
or even probably the sellers are like
how did you pick this you're like why
isn't like the YouTube algorithm but it
just picks whatever I want yeah it seems
like it cuz they're not answering the
question
pretty much yeah exactly so that's
exactly what's happening right now that
you know they're trying like reporters
and people are trying to find out like
what are you guys using to figure out
what which product you're going to have
as a Amazon's choice but why are people
worried well because people want to know
like okay are you doing this based off
of the fact that like this product here
that has been sold like let's say towels
but like this particular towel
it wasn't returned as much oh they want
you to read because this hasn't been
returned as much as the other towels or
is it based off of consumer ratings
where you know these ratings have rated
this tell the best towel that you can
get or is it based off of they based off
of the the quality and the price it's
like best bang for your buck is it based
on that
we don't know or is it based off of they
got sponsors exactly like that companies
are sponsored it like it'll say yeah
yeah yeah cuz they this anybody has to
put sponsor right even if you get paid
to put ad if you pay if you could pay
for it you have to say that II see
yeah yeah and so I think when I saw this
um I think a lot of it comes down to
like oh there's a lot of fake reviews
that push products to the top because
like people will knock off something or
whatever and create their own or
whatever but then they'll copy the
reviews from the one that was really
good and then so they pushed their
product up to the top of Amazon and now
a bunch of people are buying these
products so people are just worried
about bad reviews no like oh or Dave I
don't know how they had to prove that
you bought it I don't I think they're
still a problem a huge problem with fake
reviews really so people are like
getting broken things open things like
trashed out stuffing like this was
Amazon's choice how did how'd it like
how are y'all figuring this out if this
is what I got it son mmm so it's like
Amazon has nothing even to do what
they're happy it's just an algorithm
yeah okay so this is what we're talking
about it looks like this in case you
have it in your head yet you see this oh
yeah yeah oh I do listen to that though
I I know the times that I have listened
to this I've actually had to actually I
don't return that's a lie but I had to
throw away the products because they'll
break on me realize don't trust Amazon's
choice little badge anymore cuz I'm like
[ __ ] you guys you've failed me too many
times ten throws I didn't really notice
it is cuz I always go straight to like
the reviews they know wherever it is
yeah what happens
Amazon's choice ends up being the most
reviewed yeah does anyone use audible no
every month they give you like these
what's wrong
yeah yeah so they give you see I we all
have audible yeah I'm not there you when
they sponsor me then well I really do
have but anyway they have these like
every month they have this audible
choice I forgot what they call it but
pretty much you can get these books
without using one of your credits cuz
you get a credit every month with your
subscription and those books have the
highest ratings and like the highest
reviews and I think it's just because of
the fact that it's by that company yeah
and then that point you know they end up
getting more reviews or more because
push stars because it's pushed the top
yeah like Netflix like there's their
Netflix original they always have more
stars because it's like imagine and
Netflix originally through stars that
look so stupid oh it's always like a 98
percent match for you like it could be a
nation movie and I'm like alright got it
okay so they took away star ratings now
they just do like 98% man and whatever
I'm like you don't know me
yeah like let me see the stars if you
like to read the reviews yeah me too
cuz I feel people voting not just
Netflix giving me some number yeah yeah
so I'm saying like that sucks that you
can't really rely on what the brand is
providing for you because it's so bytes
I feel like I have a hard time shopping
on Amazon I used to like it but now I
feel like I'm trying to determine if the
reviews are real or if they're fake and
then I'm like I'll see one review the
complete opposite of what I'm one so
like I wanted this blow dryer hair thing
so it's like a brush and it like
blow-dried you're at the same time and
then like it had a thousand reviews and
it's like fifteen hundred like five
stars or whatever and then like but at
the first like one star I read I'm like
she's like oh it would pull that I
pulled out my hair burn my hair above
the boss and I'm like [ __ ] I gotta go
look for another one you know what you
got to do it's too many choices and I'd
look at the three stars yeah yeah the
best thing to do that's work [ __ ]
perfect for me is watch youtube videos
on Amazon things because people will be
like super honest most of the time
they're not sponsored and they'll tell
you like this is what I bought and like
this is how you say and like here's the
link so they'll like tell you direct so
you know what I do what do you do I just
look at the stars
yeah the number and like if it doesn't
work I'll [ __ ] return it it just
doesn't make a return Amy I like to look
at the comments for like the sizing cuz
comments will tell you if it runs large
run small oh I don't close on Amazon
ever but I but like I do if it's like a
major if it's $100 or more prisoner
maybe like a $50 or more purchase
I definitely look at the stars and then
I go to the they go to the three star
ratings because that's like the people
that are like here's the pros and cons
yeah and then I can decide if the cons
I'm like I could live with that
yeah
yeah I just go down a rabbit hole dude
I'll be there for hours and I just don't
buy anything at all yeah but that's how
you live life's jazz your your choices
better to try and fail oh it's gonna be
a flaw or someone that found a flaw in
something so the Claude choice overload
it do you guys know what you need to do
you need to go and look up like puppy
things and you look at the customer
pictures cuz then they put it on their
dogs and then they post the pictures of
their dog wet like anything like callers
and then you like scroll down and people
put like yeah it's like more like better
than Instagram like I'm you know what I
love are the really cringey reviews of
like some like middle-aged lady in a
flyover state like wanted to review it
but she made a video well you know it's
good to waiks like reviewing wigs cuz
people will like post their videos and
pictures and they're funny ya know maybe
fun of anyone but yeah I got my wakes
like a lot of times I would buy them on
Amazon wigs I thought you said Wix like
the website design and so it's it's
funny it's funny to look at like I
[ __ ] love when people are selling
mirrors oh my god yes stand in it it's
[ __ ] funny
Amazon though I feel like oh I'd rather
just buy in person I don't know you're
gonna hate me for saying you want to
waste your time I guess I can see it I
know if I really want it I don't have to
deal with like I can pick it up say yes
this is good quality or not and not have
to deal with like they shipped it to my
house I feel bad for wasting resources
sometimes I don't know where to find the
thing that I'm looking for like I can
only find it through the internet like I
don't even know what store to go I know
we have an internet play green lookin
dude pecker certain protein powders or
like specific like already clipped by
ingredients still nail polish gel nail
polish you have to buy a dog comb yeah
and you can't say Walmart because that
[ __ ] sucks and you got to get a stool
I have cordless vacuum beyond they have
no your your house on your couch Charlie
a lot for like household products like
I'm always buying mr. clean sponges and
[ __ ] but I just want to buy something I
really want I'm like oh I can't decide
you know what I hate about shopping
online especially when it comes to like
dishes or home decor
I always [ __ ] fail at this and I
should learn my lesson but I never pay
attention to the measurement like what
time I wanted to buy some clear bowls
like mixing bowls actually not that big
like maybe like this big what the [ __ ]
that's not a mixing bowl let me clarify
because as this is coming out of my
annales I remembered what it was
remember I have memory problems right
now for ants okay No so what I wanted is
like cooking videos you know the cookie
man so you have like the little dishes
to like hold ingredient the two to the
three words called oh no just like
spices and [ __ ] like your buddies all
play but they're like they're like about
this big I remember my glasses bridges
yeah so I ended up buying a set of three
because I thought they were like this
big where I could put ingredients there
Tommy ended up being this [ __ ] tight
literally this Chinese were you like cuz
I already have the sauce thingies like I
didn't need more of those sauce think
you like the pictures you can tell that
it's gonna be never good to see if they
don't customer pictures you don't buy it
no but then don't leave Miami doors and
I'm like I can't [ __ ] bad let's just
say like inches across it's like one
centimeter across on weight customer
pictures always outside of Amazon's
choice don't you always go with the
Amazon Prime option because then you get
yeah
yeah I mean you pay for it because
you're putting a membership right yeah
but it's not go free but just it happens
to me too often and then another type
you're a bad girl
Amazon it was when I forgot which
company what I was buying furniture
that's where I bought my bed frame in a
way yeah please tell me you got
something really [ __ ] she's like oh
$6 wanted this sculpture of this old
movie camera like the film cameras yes
really it looked really cool and the
[ __ ] photos are deceiving because
there's nothing to compare this so I
didn't measure that so this time it
wasn't my fault I did measure it and it
came out to be like it was supposed to
be [ __ ] decent thought should you pay
it was gonna be I can't remember any
bucks
it was not it was like fifty at least
fifty hundred that big shipping and
handling was 30 bucks maybe so and end
up coming and I was like why what was it
a bite enemy it's upstairs you I'm sure
you guys have seen it so it's like maybe
like this and like this that's 50 bucks
that's 50 but yeah so I'm like if you go
to TJ man measure their anything which
is like you're over a hundred tape
measures
I measured I am eternal a deus and a
diameter okay she's like oh that's the
one where you double it right I know
which one is it she was like yeah this
is great
no so yeah I just that's why I don't
like shopping for that stuff i buy
everything on my [ __ ] everything
everything you tell me I've bought it
you're contributing to the world under
even my car
maybe my [ __ ] car like the
transaction didn't go through but if it
did I wouldn't huh yeah the Tesla bro
you're [ __ ] rich rich it wasn't that
much it was like twenty five hundred or
five grand or something no you have to
put down like twenty five hundred five
hundred seven grand I forgot hundred Wow
she's like I named do you know like a
million bucks me yeah yeah it's my
credit card half where you buy caught
like regular cars we rent them no you
buy them really and you pick them up at
cars.com I think it's called my sponsor
or something like that and it looks like
a weird clear building yeah and like you
going like you put your coat in or
something and it's like a car vending
machine it looks weird it's like a
billiard no it's like a clear building
oh but it looks it's like a top building
and I think that the cars are just gonna
be like a vanity this is my mind in my
imagination today you can buy them
online
I just always assume when you're gonna
buy a car you have to like go and be
like no I want to pay less you know
whatever Tesla I don't know when you're
rich rich you comfy I figured out what I
believe I'm gonna be like swipe a [ __ ]
buy new my Tesla it was only twenty five
hundred down girl oh it makes me feel
good though when you have haggle and you
win yeah I do like it I walk into test
light I'm like lower they're like we
really can't do that matte blower like
listen now am i fall for 300 like well
you're gonna have to accept the premises
I will not do
[Music]